I think it's the cliche answer of yes
and no right seems like yesterday I was
I was filming my first episode of while
Abbey TV but obviously I like it said
it's an absolute lifetime ago
right they my entire career my narrative
my impact on everything I touch like the
world it's just a it's a complete
lifetime ago the day of waking up and
being a merchant and driving 45 minutes
to wine library and spending 11 hours in
that office and in that store and then
going home it just it seems so foreign I
think I had great ambition I didn't
understand how it all manifest I maybe
wouldn't understand there's a man
following me around with a camera and
that that I'm you know that I had
millions of people following me on
social networks that I didn't know
existed yet I don't think I would have
understood the details but I'm not
confused by the background
[Music]
no I don't think anybody should feel
lazy if they're not doing my thing I
think that they should feel lazy if they
spend their 12 hours day complaining
about what should be happening or how
the system's unfair to them if you're
happy you should not be feeling anything
other than gratitude but if you're
sitting with your buddies at 6:18 p.m.
at a bar complaining about the man or
the system yes if you're complete you
should be auditing and questioning
yourself we think everything is being
underestimated about what's going to
happen over the next hundred years and
everything is overestimated what's going
to happen to protect you my favorite
Australian wine is in Clinton Valley
Semyon as a category I'm a big fan it's
meekly Australian it's a flavor profile
that people don't know around the world
it's unbelievably incredibly flexible in
pairing with food Barossa Valley Shiraz
and Margaery burrs chardonnay cabernet
far more of a platform on the global
wine stage but to me Hunter Valley
Semyon is the real one you're working
one hour day and you're happiest [ __ ]
you shouldn't be questioning anything
you should be kissing the world and
thanking them for you finding your zone
I don't want people I don't want people
to be like me when it comes to my work
ethic I want people to be like me when
they found your truth
thank you brother thank you brother
thank you brother I got a run but thank
you man
stop trying to produce me tear up what's
up block me Gary a man just in here
Justin G from Venus plus beta sports all
right
anyway everybody's rooms as well we have
a really good meeting coming up I'm
excited about just had a great great
meeting with a very intriguing dude
that's all I can leave it out right now
more to come on that front Tyler and uh
don't know but I'm not a do it anyway
color do you rock that's what those
characters were full day of LA meetings
recording some really epic podcast up if
you are not subscribed to the podcast
make the commitment now leave a comment
in the YouTube section make the
commitment are you now finally in
describing on the podcast editing team
please up put a little finger with a
garyvaynerchuk.com slash I don't know
what is a podcast slash pocket I dunno
you figured out anyway
Vlad peeps love you hope you're doing
well SF night
[Music]
74 people on Instagram bring you way
more than being on a playlist on Spotify
and it's easier to accomplish that what
do you mean DMing over a course of the
year forty thousand people who have big
audiences and having twenty seven of
them is your music is equivalent to
having Spotify pick one of your songs to
be on a track yeah and then I guess that
will lead to that and you're in control
of that because it's because I'm
suffocating the conversation in a narrow
framework if you were hanging with all
your artist friends you gear off over
here and be like this is [ __ ] the
industry they don't understand like you
go all [ __ ] artsy I I'm like [ __ ]
stay right here is this doesn't matter
with mom and dad how they came up it
doesn't matter how you want it to be it
doesn't matter the fantasy story doesn't
matter to you and your musician friends
sitting around and [ __ ] complaining
about the way it is
and so you just stay there it seems
super simple because you haven't allowed
yourself that's why and that's basically
what I do with my contacts and by the
way they're uncomfortable because it
suffocates your excuses people the
reason people struggle is watching my
content at first is I'm saying the thing
they don't want to hear exactly exactly
I get it but I'm right all right we go
Custer pleasure
good luck I'll see me in a month yeah so
funny I've always been so obsessed about
my legacy the repeat I always laugh
because I have this grand ambition to
buy the New York Jets and I think that
people are so confused
it's I am so not driven by money it
actually makes me fearful like and I use
the word fearful
I'm not fearful because I know how to
create enough and like I'm practical but
the old like for me legacy is the only
thing I've ever played on it's why I
feel like I'm unbeatable
you know I but it's why you're acting in
the space in your ex-husbands you're
giving rather than trying that's right
which is my macro selfishness of what I
want which happens after I'm gone it's
really cool yeah that's right so I'm
trying to different which is why much is
why the internet really allowed me
something amazing which was I can scale
one on one at a level that has never
been done before
it's crazy perspective
it's almost a I'm only going to do one
thing for the rest of my life I'm going
to try to collect the pension and then
deploy it against you I'm great I just
walked in the door I really yes this is
home and I live five blocks down the
street now I love it a little over a
year in and did you see this proper like
on the air talking well I hear that face
my voice is making little melon
interesting real interested in it Newton
is that Oh honestly this is like
seriously like the things you don't
think about like I don't even know a
bassist like I see already know it's
like that boom boom boom like I don't
really know though no really I don't I
really know try to use ikt in your voice
yeah you get it
and that's forever yeah damn it but
that's a puberty thing I decided to jump
over I like this puberty thing seems
like it's going to slow me down
well great let's get right into it I
mean obviously I think I want to keep
all the stuff for the beginning of the
whole thing that I skipped puberty the
whole nine so anyway super excited
Zingo for the vaynernation that's
listening right now on the podcast on
the gary the audio experience why don't
you give context before we get into plan
of the apps before we get into the
experience our budding romance before we
get into all that take me all the way
back let's spend five to ten minutes
here on who you are where you came from
your narrative what is your origin story
you of the artists you know a lot of my
audience loves hip-hop because of our
infusion into it and just that vibe
who's catching your attention who's
putting out the records of the summer
who's the artist that you think is
really original you have a far more
sophisticated palette on this I'm
curious who are some of the guys or gals
that are capturing your imagination in
the hip-hop game right this second
tough oh my god so but ridiculous I'll
you know what are you listening to and
your brain just goes into this mishmash
of a thousand things you this in terms
of course the last six months but there
are some key artists that are standing
out I mean it's no strictly speaking
hip-hop but it has a hip-hop beat you
know spirit to it you know just this guy
Kalidas it's not somebody counting even
huger it's going it's already happened
that's what happening next superstar and
you know you've got all these incredible
you know artists that are just Kyle who
I know you know yep
I mean it's exciting time for I mean if
you've seen the cover of ethics of XXL
if you've seen the freshmen cover this
year it's like all those guys put
together it's it's like Slipknot or
something like there's a rock energy -
real tension to the way they represent
themselves and there's a real kind of
like visceral sort of energy to that and
I find that really interesting and I
like seeing music and and and every
layer that comes along for that ride and
it's multi-layered music is only one
aspect of the park opens the door off
off the sound and I can see I like
seeing a change off the sound people
that you've interviewed or seen interact
in real life in a board meeting or just
out in public anybody anybody stand out
that you interviewed and you're like oh
that's a person really like I'm like the
cycle JIT
he's just signed with Jay colabor
dreamville what caught your attention
there he has a complete vision how does
that happen of how he wants it to happen
he seems to be able to talk about his
dreams and his vision and his ambition
in a very methodical deliberate way so
it's not just I'm scrambling and
searching I'm going to achieve it no
matter what he's like he's got it and
when I see artists like that talk I
realized that it's not a case of if it's
a case of
when I like that it's been weird for you
two nerds to see that nerd is now
mainstream and what you loved is a kid
like Aaron let's really focus on you
because you're a big nerd right fine but
like really 37 being being the ability
to be a CT exactly like for you right
so for you that was really a different
culture is it crazy for you to see the
thing that you grew up loving now you
the 15 year old you can get the
good-looking girl not the quarterback
like does that like owning an app now is
a status symbol on Instagram because the
club promoters have come into this game
like it's just crazy isn't it yes yeah
but I mean it's awesome because that's
where the money being made that's where
the opportunity is like Apple and other
people and the art right it's not just
about money right because what I think
has really happened is app development
and this whole movement is now culture
there's a rock star status that didn't
exam I wait not super different me not
that business kids that were flipping
things like baseball cars and feelings
like that you didn't have the extreme
nerdness of like computer kids but it
wasn't sports and it wasn't music you
know entrepreneur now is that the height
of its pedestal I mean if I think it has
to start going the other way actually
pretty soon I'm enjoying these few
minutes that I have more people actually
give a [ __ ] and want to take a selfie oh
yeah oh listen I'm so pumped when
entrepreneurship isn't cool again like
because I'm never leaving right right in
college when I study computer science it
was the top of the bubbles in 2000 and
there are all these kids in my computer
science classes that didn't actually
like the work they just thought it was
hot right and then it collaterally it
collapses they all left which is kind of
cool because then the true nerds were
still in the room that's why I loved the
2003 4 5 6 7 era because the internet
was getting big enough to be real do you
guys get excited as I do that forever
forever you will be associated with
producing Apple music first original
show I mean just you know whatever
happens if there's a scene just - if
there's 30 seasons it's just always
there and I think it speaks to knowing
your guys career a little bit it's that
innovation arm right you know we you
know fashion stars I mean look I know
until you brought it up one day in the
trailer I didn't know that
you guys I didn't know the Hollywood
landscape could mean that was just very
smart and for me that's like credit I
think in a lot of ways this new
distribution obviously Netflix and other
otps exist but let's call it what it is
this is the most powerful company in the
world at this moment this is their first
foray into something that you guys grew
up in right like you know to me a lot of
this has happened backwards
entrepreneurship and it's backed into
culture this is what you guys dreamed
and aspired to do your whole life it
must be pretty fantastic it were second
everything and I'll just say that one of
the things that has been really one of
the things that has been such a great
gift is that Apple is really supported
creative from the beginning we pitched
in the show they liked the idea and they
really allowed us to make it and they're
really kind of there's no surprise that
great things happen here and that you
know they've been responsible for some
of the most innovative things things
launches ever and they support creative
thinking well design design is such a
core back to the the culture of the
company and so we're all kind of
designers in this convergent world
whether were you know tech entrepreneurs
video makers platform builders there's
an element of design and aesthetic that
permeates everything we're all doing
especially the label that's right so
what else has been weird
what's as an aspiring entrepreneur you
know you grew up in a household that
really understood entertainment at the
highest levels what has been the biggest
iOpener about entrepreneurship how much
work yes great answer cooler environment
I love it
come on love it boom so um first things
first
these are for the little things that
like that play between the song yet on
the radio yeah you should know all that
kind of [ __ ] let's just get a couple of
different just beat one beat one yep
just beat one beats one back to Mike a
little bit thanks one is let's do a the
beat one list the beats one list and
give me a sane low Zane Lowe next on the
beach one list okay back to the mic next
on the beach one list next on the beach
one list amazing okay now we're going to
switch them if I am not the voice of an
animated character in a Disney film in
the next six years I'm going to get some
but I'll make your demo god I'm done
dude I want it I want to be a squirrel
just incredible day right now in the
beat studios over here an apple and LA
got a ton of podcast work done so you'll
be hearing a bunch of podcast original
podcast stuff and some promos for beats
one so hopefully you're listening to
that on Apple music and you'll hear my
voice come through real good good day
that was really good
d Rock just missed did not capture one
of the great quotes in daily the history
but it's actually not part of the only
history cuz missed and D rock sorry
Tyler
mr. but you loved it follows I'll tell
you guys a story cuz I'm good dude key
rock just said hey what do you think
about getting a second camera while we
travel so in case I got to do some stuff
where I can put a camera on you and get
the guest what have you and I was like
okay I can't I recognize you now I've a
voice I see I'd give or take and I see I
sent to my television you will talk
about you need to recreate yourself to
be strong to open the internet and
figure out what's going wrong bro I'm a
big fan
thank you my friend thank you so much
[Music]
how are you
I'm sorry Tabitha you come with a group
[Music]
it's like a 20 second tour guys oh how
are you yes send this Beko yeah now the
reason I have a channel and you know
reason I have a job look wrangled
introduced so what happens like when
you're just like feel like this will
definitely like what is life yeah
basically awesome it's a real pleasure
meeting you guys
yeah have a big thing a little bit yeah
my said yes it's literally like Murphy
hi-yah - though it's not a choice that's
right I have many things on my face on
it
doodle proud of you you signed a lot
thank you dude it's real work for our
subscription thing yeah her to Franco
elite thing I'm dying to hear the update
in the bathroom woman yes the luxury of
like being around this yeah I don't know
when you start like you've always had to
know some version of me from way back
when
um just it's the long game well they're
not any people I can say it right not
here that's right it's the long game and
so like it's fun for like I'm definitely
in a moment right now but it's just
another moment you know like I've had my
moments right like were you around when
I I got on Conan and like everybody
freaked out about that that was what
that was July 2007 that was not well
that's really early on for yeah I got on
Conan and everybody lost her [ __ ] like
every blog everybody on early early
Twitter was like I just remember
everybody
I remember being backstage and I just
seen they what's her man she's some
other Kara what's the girl with a on
revision3 Veronica Belmont like all
these people were DMing me Coors we
think like everybody was just like
basically like do it for off and I'm
like [ __ ] I you know that's like it was
such a cool moment like every like Peter
Gruber for like you know from Apple
blogs like everybody wrote about it so
early for somebody from the internet to
be on real TV
what were they even asked me that that
was like so people are looking at you
you mean on Conan we did a wineskin
we tasted why'd that work them it worked
out but it was just uh it was such a dip
like revision like right like like Kevin
oh yeah Wow diggnation diggnation was
such a big deal that was like it was big
nation rocketboom and as a prank I think
that was like the Mount Rushmore yeah I
think the moment
realized that I have it may be a long
term businesses when I found out the
numbers of the Ignatian was doing I was
like oh okay I can do this
Bofur for sales and 100% was like oh you
were bigger and diggnation real fast
because they were insular YouTube had so
much more scale behind it right what was
good about their show though was their
shows served a bigger purpose aim is
long but that's that's what I'm trying
to get you right now
yeah don't think of it as transactional
understand how young and how or if you
were you know what your biggest
disadvantages you've been in the game
for so long you don't have in my opinion
right off the bat I can taste it I don't
think you've contextualized how early we
are in this whole game because you got
all the great pieces man [ __ ] [ __ ]
doesn't happen by accident
yeah producing a show the way you do
that's work yeah in a very different way
just documenting and letting people I'm
producing the show that I would have
wanted to watch as a business kid when I
was 16 I would have wanted to watch
somebody who's doing what I wanted to do
to see if I could have picked up on her
or his cadence timing information like
just stop well that's good you know I
think sorry what you scratching your own
itch is the model yes my man great to
see ya Oh guys we solve everything
blueprint is set you guys won
I'll see you guys later good luck with
everything bye thank you thanks for
having me
this is a nerd palace since you don't
ever go again
hi guys so you get a plaque in a million
subscribers yeah all right
so litter
[Music]
oh my god they're not joking around here
Wow that's what Apple music will help
right now would you doubt sister Gary
shut up
[Music]